All right. So, good morning. My name is
Mark Mashottton. I'm our enterprise AI
architect at Los Alamos National
Laboratory. Uh, today, you know, this is
an AI conference. What What's a nuclear
science lab doing here? The reality is
we've actually been doing applied a IML
for almost 70 years. Uh this is actually
one of our scientists in 1956
uh playing Los Alamos chess uh in front
of one of our first supercomputers,
Maniac 1. And what's unique about this
is we if you look at it, there's
actually no bishops on the chessboard.
You know, we we've been doing applied
statistics and applied machine learning
since we didn't have the memory needed
to hold an entire chessboard in a
computer at once. And that's fascinating
to to say back when this photo was
taken, it was after the Manhattan
project, we were pushing the edge of
developing Monte Carlo methods that we
still use today. And for us, you know,
AI didn't come as a complete surprise,
but the opportunity that's come with
agents, with things we can do has been
incredible even to to us that have been
along the right the ride for quite some
time.
Uh, let's see if I can make this full
screen.
So, what we have going on here, this is
actually a demonstration. You can find
it on our YouTube channel if you can't
see it on the screen here, but we've
looked at generative AI, not only from a
strict model standpoint, but also from
an agentic standpoint as a way for us to
move science faster. You know, we we
like much of the federal government are
under a squeeze to do better, faster,
cheaper, and more to protect our
country. And in this case, you going
from not just what a model knows, but
what we can let a model know was really
the the change that happened here. We
started with a problem of go design an
ICF, an inertial confinement fusion
capsule for our sister lab at Liverour
across the bay here. and we said, "Read
a paper. Go read lots of papers that you
think are tangential to this first paper
and then come up with a design for a
fusion capsule." Uh, it created a
hypothesis. And the thing that's kind of
uniquely ours is this isn't a generic,
you know, chatbot that spits back a
bunch of code. What you'll see here in a
second, we're actually executing that
code on our high performance computing
assets. And we are actually running, you
know, thermodynamic hydrodnamic tests on
some of these types of problems where
our model, you know, isn't just an LLM.
It's all of the, you know, 50 60 plus
years of math and science that we've
done to to bring the the management and
the development of our nuclear stockpile
and stewardship of that stockpile, bring
those tools into an agentic era. So,
we're looking at this as a chance for
agents to move faster uh and for for
science to move faster because the risk
at the same time is starting to move
faster. You can see here it actually did
come up with a design that it thought
optimize that yield and we were
simulating a slice through an ICF
capsule.
But, okay, that's one nice toy problem.
What does that mean for the other 20,000
researchers that we have at our
laboratory? For those of you not
familiar, we're 40 square miles of labs,
test sites, uh, test plants. We have 13
nuclear facilities. And so, we're huge.
We have a huge breath of what we're
trying to accomplish with AI, uh, and
getting our mission moving faster. For
our national security AI office, you
know what you just saw, that's the first
thing of that we're charged with. Push
the science of AI faster. Don't just sit
there and consume commercial tools or
open source tools. We write our stuff.
We write our own models. Uh we also
realize that we can't do everything. We
don't have the hubris to understand or
to say here and oh we understand
everything. We don't need anyone's help.
We absolutely need those partnerships
from commercial industry from academia.
And then just like the rest of you all
here, we're looking at how do we bring
AI and Gen AI tools into our workflows.
You know, we have a huge footprint. We
have to do payroll. We have to do
procurement. We have to do cyber
security. And so our office is kind of
in there. How do we do that? And it
really does come down some to some of
what we're doing with our partners. We
have some great academic partners. We
couldn't at the time these slides were
released for uh public review, we didn't
get the screenshot on there. We also
announced a partnership with the UC
family of schools uh on the academic
side of developing, you know, the future
of AI. But we're also working with all
the frontier labs. you know, here's a
couple press releases where we've
actually done chem biosafety work with
open AAI and we we've been able to
acknowledge that work that we've done
with them, but we have a place where
we've been doing we're a safe place to
do dangerous things and we've been doing
that for decades. So, it's a neat
partnership to have these frontier labs
that really can't afford to hire anyone
they want still come to us as a source
of data and a source of partnership.
There in the middle of that last
picture, we actually have science of AI
in the hardware space. Uh that's our
Venado supercomputer. It's over 2500
nodes of GraceHopper super chips and we
we brought it um through a partnership
with open or with um Nvidia and uh HPE
to build a supercomput that can help us
push the boundaries of what does it mean
to do AI research. And then more
recently, we've also brought OpenAI's
models onto this system, brought it up
to our classified networks, and we're
getting to work on the really hard
problems that are unique to our data and
our mission space.
When we talk about agents, you know,
partnerships take trust, you know,
certainly having labs trust you with
early access to their models or model
weights. As we talk about sharing
responsibility with our partners,
certainly the responsibility of what our
AI tools and services do starts to
matter. Uh there were previous
administration had certain executive
orders out. Those were replaced largely
in January when the new administration
took change. But this piece of OM
memorandum just came out in April. Uh
M2521 and there's M2522.
And it starts to codify like what things
should the US government start to worry
about when we're fielding these AI
systems. It tells the government to go
faster. That's important. But it also
says these government type workloads,
they have real world impacts. You know,
for us, we are not a t-shirt company. If
our data gets out, that's, you know,
geopolitical challenges show up. Uh
kinetic challenges show up. People can
die if we do this wrong. And this I
won't bore you. It's like 25 pages,
reasonably well written for an OMB
memorandum as far as readability and
comprehensiveness, but it says we as the
US government need to move faster into
bringing this into everything we do.
It's not enough to just buy, you know,
pick your favorite office addin tool and
say we can type powerpoints faster or
summarize our emails faster. We got to
go deeper into our mission and that
comes with trust. So, who here is part
of a software as a service uh company or
startup?
Okay, handful of hands here. So, you've
probably seen something similar to this,
especially if you've been in the cloud
space recently, that as us as customers
start to trust you with our data, your
responsibility also comes up. Uh that's
easy to do for our open public
unrestricted data like the open science
work like I showed off of our ICF
capsule agent. But as we get into
controlled and classified, as we get
into classified and the DOE space, as we
get into restricted and formerly
restricted data, where the physics of
how nuclear weapons work don't expire,
that that will forever be classified.
It's born, classified, and stays
classified. It takes an element of trust
in you all as our builders, as our
providers. And this is really some of
the most interesting and unfrusting
conversations we have with companies
trying to sell us tools and services is
great. You have your sock 2 report. I
have NIST 853. This is actually rev 4.
It's over a,000 different security
controls and enhancements. And the the
US government has put a lot of
legislation in place to do traditional
cyber security work. Fed Ramp certainly
tried to make this easier by coming in
and saying, you know, 200 your security
controls, 300, 400 have been vetted with
a third party authorizer. You have some
continuous monitoring. Has anyone here
been downstream of the Fed ramp process?
Yeah, I see a couple smiles. So, you
know how much of a pain this has been.
And much like everything else in the
government right now, it is changing.
There's a new Fed ramp program out there
saying if we're going to trust you with
our data, if we're going to trust trust
you with the outcomes of our agents, you
have to start thinking about your
continuous monitoring, your continuous
security posture. Uh if you work with
the DoD, that gets even harder. Uh DoD
has what they call their security
requirements guide or CCSRG. Um it talks
about if you're touching this type of
data level. So it takes that three types
or three types of Fed ramp. It layers on
two more uh impact levels as the DoD
calls them and says this is how you're
going to access that service if you have
PII or mission data or operational data
or finance data. And then they add
another copy of this book, you know,
CNSSI 1253 on top of that. So if if
you're looking at this saying it's a lot
of governance, it is. Um but the fun
part is right now where we are today
from those uh April 3rd memorandums is
AI use cases, AI governance is still on
the drawing board. Like we are in that
180day rulemaking period that these uh
pieces of OM memoranda put out saying
agent or agencies have to go develop
their strategies, their plans for
developing you know AI implementations.
How do you govern pilots? What's
considered high-risisk, lowrisisk in
your context? And there's some
prescriptive guidance out there. NIST
back in 2023 released their AI risk
management framework.
>> Breakout sessions will begin in 5
minutes.
>> Five minutes for morning breakout
sessions. [laughter]
>> Your choice.
>> But the fun part is you can develop the
future with your customers right now.
Now, this is a clean sheet of paper from
a technology perspective that we largely
haven't had to tackle. Uh, and it's it's
fun in a US government space to say we
can invent part of the future together
with commercial industry. Um, make
hopefully better, less obnoxious, less
obstructive decisions so we can keep
moving mission faster. And and if it
sounds like this is a lot of lawyers and
paperwork, it probably is. Um, there
there's no getting around. Some of these
records and artifacts do have to exist.
But the the reason you'd want to
collaborate with us is we're doing
things that are either incredibly hard
or can't be done in commercial industry.
Um, at least at Los Alamos, we are
sitting on pabytes of data that has
never seen the internet, will never see
the internet. Uh we have subject matter
expertise in chem uh bio materials
physics um materials composites um
certainly cyber security and the design
of high performance computing that some
of the partnerships I mentioned earlier
and they can be your partnerships too.
You know we we firmly believe that if
we're talking about taking care of the
country taking care of our national
competitive advantage that's not just a
bunch of scientists sitting on a
mountain side in Los Alamos that are
going to figure that out. We really do
want your help and your uh engagement
with us to you know push the boundaries
of what we know. This was originally
meant to be an architecture talk. So
finishing up with an architecture slide.
If you are interested in bringing a
agentic tools, agentic services to the
federal government. There's really four
things to think about. You know, we want
to see that you've built for
explanability. Our keynote this morning
touched on that a little bit of how did
you get to that decision? you know, if
if something goes wrong or if we have a
bad day, we don't have shareholders that
we're responsible to. We have the US
citizens to be responsible to. Um, we
have whatever that outcome was that, you
know, caused some press briefing. We
need to be able to trust our agents the
same way we trust our staff. Uh, when we
talk about fielding things, again, we we
are not a t-shirt company. Building for
isolation matters. And um I was looking
forward to seeing Microsoft's demo on
the uh
self-hosted uh AI foundry pieces, but
for us, we do that anyways. We look and
leverage heavily open-source tools and
services and models to do some of this
work because we can't get it from a
hyperscaler cloud provider. Uh so as
you're building your tools and services,
take a look at some of those services in
scope page. Even if you are a SAS
startup, um if you can build in a DoD
impact level 5 environment with that
limited number of services from your
cloud vendor, you can deploy anywhere.
You know, you you have the least common
denominator uh out of that entire tech
stack. If you can deploy your, you know,
your tool, your application there, that
makes our job easier. That makes you
more portable.
And as along with that comes build for
governance. We also have some awkward
conversations with customers where it's
well we need a software bill of
materials as we're doing this
procurement with you and yeah [laughter]
uh people look at us like I mean I guess
we can dump you know what we had in our
build script and it's it's a little bit
of an awkward conversation but that's
required per our regs you know AI stuff
is moving a mile a minute the
traditional cyber security stuff is
moving faster but not quite there yet so
if you can plan to have those
conversations of how did you handle open
source dependencies. What are your
patching plans? What you know, help us
fill this paperwork out if we're buying
from you as a software as a service or
platform as a service. That makes that
entire partnership that much faster,
that much more friendly. And lastly,
keep up the speed.
We have also had some awkward
conversations with some of our service
providers saying, why is your federal
stuff a year out of date? you know, why
is that service par not happening a
year, three years, five years uh from
when you launched it in a commercial
region? And that's not us just liking
ourselves and wanting to have bravado
that oh, we're the government, we we're
a quasi federal agency, we we care about
our data. No, this is rooted in export
compliance law. This is things like we
can't buy from you unless you're in the
right places. Um so it's if you can
design for speed in your hard corners
that optimizes your chances of uh
fielding your tools and services with us
uh in different places that we have to
operate to meet our mission
and and with that I lo Alamos we were
founded on the idea that the right
application of math and science can
change the world overnight. Um we we've
done that. We're not a stranger to how
that feels to show up and the world is
now different. Uh that's what we were
founded to do. And when we look at AI,
uh Aentic tools, what we can do with
frontier models, any of the above, um we
see it as the greatest opportunity and
the greatest threat to national
security, but the opportunity is what
keeps us showing up. We're not scared of
the the downside risk. We have to be
here to help develop the future. Uh, one
of my favorite anecdotes, uh, because we
are a nuclear science lab, uh, we do a
lot of nuclear non-prololiferation work.
And because we do that type of work,
we've gotten really good at specialty
sensors. And what have we been able to
do with that specialty sensor? We have a
laser strapped to a car on Mars zapping
rocks. You know, we built the ChemCam
sensor. So even if you're a little bit
on the fence about should we engage
with, you know, the nuclear enterprise
of the US, there's other fundamental
science that we do that's just pushing
the boundaries that we as a human
species know and can do and can can grow
into. So with that, thank you so much
for your time today. I really appreciate
it and I'll be available on the side for
questions. Thank you.